ist auch im dritten wahlgang die
mehrheit der stimmen erforderlich also
thüringen hat hier keine
verfassungsrechtliche besonderheit
gewählt sondern durchaus ein gängiges
auslegungs muster es gab aber bisher
noch keinen fall weder bei der
kanzlerwahl noch bei der wahl eines
ministerpräsidenten bei der hinterher
dann ein gericht mit der auslegung
dieser rechtsfrage befasst wurde
vielleicht werden wir das in thüringen
erleben und vielleicht wird es dann
irgendwann mal ein
eine entscheidung des thüringer
verfassungsgerichtshofes geben wie denn
das mehrheits erfordernis im dritten
wahlgang tatsächlich aus zu gestalten
und zu verstehen ist es hieß immer dass
das alles nur ein rolle spielt wenn ein
einzelner kandidat im dritten wahlgang
antritt das heißt sobald ein
gegenkandidat kommt es dass alles
absolut so ist es wenn ein kandidat
ansteht dann taucht oder zur wahl steht
dann taucht die frage natürlich auf
welche mehrheit ist erforderlich müssen
die nein stimmen berücksichtigt werden
oder nicht stehen zwei oder mehr
kandidaten zur wahl ist es relativ
einfach der der dann die relative
mehrheit auf sich vereinigt im konzert
dieser zwei oder drei kandidaten
der ist dann gewählt diese frage wer
rechtlich unproblematisch das ist meine
gedanken dritten wahlgang kein nein
kreuzer ist so ist es ja also wir werden
sehen wie die landtagspräsidentin das
problem dass verfassungsrechtliche
probleme angeht und ob dann
gegebenenfalls hinterher
der verfassungsgerichtshof in weimar
über diese rechtsfrage um die es ja hier
tatsächlich geht entscheiden wird ist
auch für ein verfassungsrechtler
entspannter tag oder so ist es in der
tat vor allem halten sich die kommentare
auch mit der auslegung dieser
rechtsfrage sehr deutlich zurück die
juristische fachliteratur ist also
durchaus umstritten und strittig
vielleicht schafft dann der thüringer
verfassungsgerichtshof irgendwann mal
klarheit in der tat wir schauen noch
einmal runter ins plenum zu sehen was
passiert was wir sehen ist dass die sp
fraktion geschlossen noch nicht da ist
das erkennt man wenn man so geradeaus
nach hinten schaut hier sehen wir sie
die ränge sind der jetzt kommt die erste
abgeordnete als er also genau gerade
platz für die ard und jetzt trudeln auch
weitere 1
es gab sicherlich gesprächsbedarf davon
kann man ausgehen wie geht man weiter er
wird sicherlich ein gewichtiges wort
mitgesprochen haben der
fdp fraktionschef und die große frage
wird sein zieht die afg jetzt ihren
kandidaten zurückführen dritten wahlgang
für wie wahrscheinlich halten sie das
professor produkts ich rechne nicht
unbedingt damit weil dann würde in der
tat auch die fdp herr kemmerich nicht
nominieren und mein eindruck ist in der
tat man will schon eine entscheidung
herbeiführen zwischen personen in dem
dritten wahlgang
was wir glaube ich nicht wissen ist in
der tat wie die position des kandidaten
kindervater selbst sitzt vielleicht
hatte er auch der fraktion signalisierte
im vorfeld wenn es nach den ersten zwei
wahlgängen nicht danach aussieht dass
ich einigermaßen stimmen von cdu oder
fdp gewinnen kann stehe ich vielleicht
auch gar nicht zur verfügung wäre doch
mal daran an die stimmenzahl im ersten
wahlgang hat herr kindervater 22 25
stimmen bekommen im zweiten bahn ist
dann nur noch 22 und das sind genau die
stimme der afd
dh je entscheidender die frage wird
desto eher scheinen sich die cdu
möglichen cdu abweichler von ihm weg zu
bewegen und vielleicht hat er sich das
vorbehalten auch deswegen diese pause
gebeten noch einmal darüber beraten zu
lassen
das könnte auch sein die reihen füllen
sich unter uns im landtag es ist noch
etwas unruhig es wird viel gesprochen es
gibt sicherlich viel gesprächsbedarf
hier vorne im gang steht herr adams das
ist der fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen
deren fraktion ja auf fünf abgeordnete
zusammengeschrumpft ist und in wenigen
augenblicken wird dann die
landtagspräsidentin oben vom präsidium
aus die sitzung fortsetzen und dann sind
wir sehr gespannt denn dann wird sie
abfragen welche kandidaten sich denn
hier jetzt zur wahl stellen welche also
antreten werden
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir setzen
in der sitzung fort befinden uns vor dem
dritten wahlgang
ich frage gibt es ergänzungen zu den
jetzt hier vorliegenden vorschlägen
vorgeschlagen ist herr abgeordneter bodo
ramelow
die fdp fraktion wollte sich nochmal
äußern bitte ansonsten bleibt das bei
herrn kindervater das sehe ich richtig
ja gibt es weitere bemerkungen in dem
wahlgang anträge herr montag abgeholt
oder montag bitte für die fdp fraktion
darf ich ihnen thomas kemmerich
vorschlagen vielen dank
dann befinden sich auf unserem baans
wahlzettel drei namen vorgeschlagen für
diesen dritten wahlgang sind erneut herr
abgeordneter bodo ramelow
herr christoph kindervater außerdem hat
die fraktion der fdp herrn abgeordneten
thomas kemmerich vorgeschlagen
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
brauchen um die drucksache entsprechend
auszufertigen 20 minuten damit
unterbreche ich die sitzung für 20
minuten 13 5 wird fortgesetzt
zur erklärung was jetzt passiert ist mal
was ganz im hintergrund ganz leicht
gehört es kam ein mitarbeiter der
verwaltung ging an den tisch und sprach
mit der landtagspräsidentin keller was
da passiert ist
und zwar geht es um folgendes ist man
muss jetzt erstmal diesen wahlzettel
drucken
das heißt es gibt natürlich
vorbereitungen für die einzelnen
wahlgänge aber man braucht diesen
stimmzettel auf dem jetzt eben diese
kandidaten die jetzt gerade abgefragt
wurden dann auch wirklich drauf stehen
dafür gibt es ein landtags druckerei und
dort wird jetzt kräftig gedruckt das
dauert wahrscheinlich 20 minuten deshalb
hier die unterbrechung ist ist ja
bereits die dritte heute finden sie das
ungewöhnliche und beunruhigend 9 weder
beunruhigend noch sonstwie irgendwie
problematisch ist vielmehr im
parlamentarischen verfahren üblich wenn
solche wichtigen fragen an stehen und es
geht ja immerhin um die wahl des
ministerpräsidenten
das dann den fraktionen auch gelegenheit
und zeit eingeräumt wird um sich zu
beraten wenn jetzt noch diese
stimmzettel gedruckt werden müssen wir
haben es gehört die drucksache muss erst
noch auf den weg gebracht werden
dann ist das auch ein gängiger
parlamentarischer vorgang man hätte sich
aber natürlich schon die frage stellen
können im vorfeld ob man nicht solche
optionen hätte im vorfeld
berücksichtigen können oder vielleicht
sogar müssen und entsprechende
stimmzettel schon im vorfeld vorbereiten
können die frage kann man glaube ich
stellen wiederum war ja trotzdem nicht
wirklich klar wie sich die cdu verhalten
oder gestern kam zwar das signal aus der
cdu sie würde keinen eigenen kandidaten
stellen
aber ich glaube viele haben doch nicht
dran geglaubt dass am ende sich wirklich
niemand aus der cdu-fraktion die
eigentlich den ministerpräsidenten
ablösen wollte bei dieser wahl ja von
der sache bin ich da völlig bei ihnen da
hätte man eigentlich nicht daran glauben
können gerade eine partei die sich das
regieren selbst in die dna geschrieben
hat stellt keinen eigenen
ministerpräsidentenkandidaten auch
andererseits haben wir heute auch schon
erläutert die cdu hat gestern abend noch
mal sehr deutlich gemacht dass sie das
nicht tun wird insofern war es dann in
diesem kurzen zeithorizont dann auch zu
erwarten an dieser stelle wohl das
erstaunlichste es gab ja durchaus
bewerber in der cdu auch aus der
thüringer cdu heraus mitglieder
bundestagsabgeordnete herr weiler aus
dem bundestagsabgeordneten so alle
holzland kreis der hat gesagt ich stünde
zur verfügung
ist es aber nicht geworden in der tat
war das natürlich auch die frage
aufgeworfen hätte warum steht eigentlich
der fraktionsvorsitzende nicht zur
verfügung an dieser stelle das wollte
man vermeiden wie man diese ganze
debatte ernsthaft offensichtlich
vermieden hat in den letzten wochen
man geht hier offenen auges in eine
situation ich glaube ohne plan und hofft
jetzt vermutlich darauf dass man
vielleicht mit herrn kemmerich zusammen
ein gutes ergebnis darstellen kann was
diese beiden fraktionen angeht aber auch
greift die nicht auch ein kemmerich wird
das ist jetzt in diesem dritten wahlgang
vielleicht nur pro forma herrn
kindervater vorgeschoben hat und jetzt
geschlossen für herrn kemmerich stimmt
dann hätte die cdu auch ein problem die
fdp hätte das problem endlich glaube das
ist in der tat das kalkül der cdu wenn
wir dabei sind weil man hat gesagt man
lässt keinen ministerpräsidenten aus den
eigenen reihen durch die fdp wählen
jetzt hat man einen mit der afg gewählt
dazu gab es noch nicht so eine ganz
eindeutige sprachregelung bis dahin ist
auch kein afg kandidat sondern ein
fdp-kandidat damit könnte man glaube ich
sehr gut leben
ich glaube die probleme vor der tür hat
dann herr kemmerich jetzt schauen wir
erst einmal schwierige situation die
sache ist unterbrochen wie war
eigentlich an diesem punkt gekommen sind
also was ich in den letzten gut 100
tagen abgespielt hat dass wir jetzt hier
im landtag im dritten wahlgang nach der
dritten unterbrechung darüber
diskutieren wer mit wem welche mehrheit
und überhaupt der wahlabend am 27
oktober hat die politische landschaft in
thüringen völlig verändert erstmals nur
die linke stärkste kraft in einem
bundesdeutschen parlament die ard kommt
auf platz zwei herbe verluste von rund
11% punkten dagegen für die cdu auch die
sozialdemokraten verlieren deutlich
werden einstellig ihr bisher
schlechtestes ergebnis in thüringen bis
zum schluss mussten die grünen und die
fdp zittern
zwischenzeitlich waren beide nicht im
siebten thüringer landtag vertreten
zwar ist bodo ramelow der wahlsieger
aber sein rot rot grünes bündnis hat
keine mehrheit mehr
der tag nach der wahl mike mohring
bietet den linken indirekt eine
zusammenarbeit an
ich muss die debatten in thüringen
führen und nicht in berlin und alle
beschlusslagen die irgendjemand gefasst
hat waren vor diesem wahlergebnis weil
sich auch niemand vorstellen konnte
berechtigterweise dass die politische
mitte keine mehrheit mehr hat
doch die anschließende
cdu-präsidiumssitzung macht klar es wird
keine zusammenarbeit mit den linken
geben so wie es ein bundesparteitag
beschlossen hat noch am abend kommt die
cdu zu einer krisensitzung in erfurt
zusammen auch dort wird die
zusammenarbeit mit den linken und der
afg strikt abgelehnt dafür bringen die
christdemokraten eine sogenannte sympath
für koalition aus cdu spd fdp und grünen
ins gespräch
eine koalition die ebenfalls keine
mehrheit hätte die ablehnung der
sozialdemokraten folgt prompt wir wollen
nicht nur für cdu und fdp die
möglichkeit geben sich vorhaben ein zu
schließen sondern wir wollen auch im
umgang im parlament deutlich machen dass
die spd eine ganz eigenständige kraft
ist in der zwischenzeit liegt sich bodo
ramelow festival rot-rot-grün fortsetzen
wegen der fehlenden mehrheit als
minderheitsregierung im november
beginnen die sondierungsgespräche
unterdessen fordert altbundespräsident
joachim gauck von der cdu eine
zusammenarbeit mit den linken und
schlägt ein treffen zwischen gudow
ramelow und mike mohring und aus seiner
vermittlung vor und ex-ministerpräsident
dieter althaus bringt eine so genannte
projekt regierung zwischen linken und
cdu ins spiel
also eine zusammenarbeit bei bestimmten
themen mitte januar treffen sich ramelow
mohring und gauck in erfurt einen tag
vor gesprächen zwischen rot-rot-grün den
christdemokraten und den liberalen
auch hier soll eine mögliche
zusammenarbeit ausgelotet werden ohne
ergebnis aber bestimmte dinge aus ihren
wahlprogrammen wie mehr lehrer oder mehr
polizisten wollen alle durchsetzen kann
es ganz bunte mehrheiten geben die wir
alle kennen das stadthaus kreistagen und
deshalb müssen wir genau da neu denken
nicht in allen parteien blöcken erst
recht nicht einem rot-rot-grünen blog zu
sagen okay die gute idee muss nach vorne
am schluss der rot-rot-grünen
sondierungen heißt es aus
verhandlungskreisen
das ist nicht immer einfach war auch ein
scheitern wäre möglich gewesen
einer der gründe die forderungen der
grünen waren oft selbstbewusster als es
ihr wahlergebnis zuließ ende januar
stimmen spd und grüne auf parteitagen
den koalitionsvertrag mit den linken zu
und auch bei den linken entscheiden sich
die mitglieder für den vertrag und dem
wagnis einer minderheitsregierung
aber noch ist das alles nicht so weit
wir sind jetzt nach dem zweiten wahlgang
in beiden bei gegen hat bodo ramelow
noch keine mehrheit geholt jetzt ist die
sitzung zum dritten mal unterbrochen
der dritte wahlgang wird vorbereitet und
in dem werden dann drei kandidaten also
bodo ramelow mit zwei gegenkandidaten
antreten
lasst uns die gelegenheit gibt einmal
nach berlin zu schauen wo man mit
sicherheit mit argusaugen nach thüringen
blickt für uns dort vor ort ist mein
kollege markus rehr der ja das ganze
geschehen auch von den parteizentralen
aus verfolgt und sich anhört was dort
gesprochen wird markus wie sieht es denn
aus gips reaktionen auf ja jetzt diesen
anstehenden dritten wahlgang
ja es gibt vor allen dingen gespanntes
warten wie dieser wahlgang ausgehen mag
das ist ja für cdu und fdp ein hohes
risiko ich hatte gestern hier in berlin
noch gelegenheit mit dem kandidaten der
jetzt seinen hut in den ring wirft mit
thomas kemmerich zu sprechen er gab ihr
einen hintergrund für uns
hauptstadtjournalisten und er sieht
durchaus die gefahr dass die afg hier
nicht sauber spielen könnte so
formulierte er das ungefähr spricht dass
die fdp ihren kandidaten jetzt ins
rennen schickt aber dann gar nicht für
ihn stimmt sondern ihn thomas kemmerich
die fdp unterstützt und dann hätte man
eine jedoch gelinde gesagt merkwürdige
situation darstellt eine partei die ganz
wenige stimmen nur gewonnen hat den
ministerpräsidenten und muss sich dazu
auch noch von der afg unterstützen
lassen dass es eine befürchtung die die
fdp hier umtreibt und das wäre
sicherlich auch kein gutes bild für die
cdu apropos cdu das problem besteht ja
auch hätte eine mehrheit gegeben
zwischen linker und cdu und mike mohring
klang nach der wahl eigentlich so als
hätte er da durchaus ambitionen weil er
die notwendigkeit sieht weil das
wahlergebnis eben das war was es war ist
da aber aus berlin ganz fix
zurückgepfiffen worden welche rolle hat
die cdu-spitze da gespielt und zu sagen
rot und schwarz zusammen das geht nicht
ja wenn man das so salopp formulieren
will die bundes cdu hat mike mohring
ganz deutlich heim geleuchtet
es gab sehr heftige kritik großes
kopfschütteln hier in berlin
was mike mohring ideen an ging man könne
in irgendeiner art und weise mit der
linkspartei hinter bodo ramelow in
thüringen kooperieren zusammenzuarbeiten
da hat man deutlich abgelehnt die
linkspartei seine nachfolgepartei der
sed mit der könne man nicht zusammen
arbeiten
unter gar keinen umständen ich habe
heute früh mit dem konrad
genau hause telefonieren können man
scheint jetzt etwas entspannter zu sein
zumindest was projektarbeit angeht da
wolle man der landes-cdu nicht im wege
stehen wenn es etwa darum geht mehr
lehrer mehr polizisten oder mehr
autobahnkilometer für thüringen dann
wolle man da die thüringer landes-cdu
walten und schalten lassen
da wolle man als bundes-cdu nicht im
wege stehen markus wenn man noch einmal
jetzt darauf schaut was ich hier gerade
abspielt um das mal ein bisschen
einzuordnen kann man so weit gehen zu
sagen dass man vielleicht in berlin
sogar ein wenig angst davor hat was
jetzt hier in thüringen im dritten
wahlgang passieren könnte ich hätte das
ja bereits erwähnt ist ein großes risiko
wie hören aus cdu kreisen dass die cdu
herr kemmerich unterstützt aber stellen
sie sich vorher wird tatsächlich auch
mit stimmen der afg gewählt dann hätte
man eine regierungskoalition in
thüringen
gestützt von der cdu unterstützt auch
von der afg und das ist eigentlich so
hören wir dass zumindest in berlin
was weder die fdp noch die cdu wollte
vielen dank markus reha nach berlin und
professor brothers da fragen wir gleich
noch mal bei ihnen nach markus hat das
ganze als ein merkwürdiges ergebnis
bezeichnet was eben möglich wäre wenn
tatsächlich thomas kemmerich von der fdp
mit stimmen der afg gewählt wurde weil
die nämlich einen eigenen kandidaten im
dritten wahlgang gar nicht stützt halten
sie das für eine wahrscheinliche
möglichkeit das ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich biaggi hat einmal einen
kandidaten der nicht aus der eigenen
fraktion der nicht aus der partei kommt
also sie schädigt nicht unmittelbar
jemand aus ihrem engeren führung fällt
wenn sie ihn jetzt nicht mehr
unterstützt im dritten wahlgang
sie kann in der öffentlichkeit auch sehr
deutlich machen unser kandidat hat in
den ersten zwei wahlgängen nicht die
unterstützung bekommen die wir uns
erhofft hatten
aber wir wollen eine regierungsmehrheit
jenseits von rot-rot-grün und deswegen
haben wir uns geschlossen
überlegt im dritten wahlgang kemmerich
zu wählen und wenn danach fragen kommt
warum stellen sie dann ihren kandidaten
noch auf wird man sagen na ja die fdp
hat nur dann ihre bereitschaft erklärt
einen anderen kandidaten ins rennen zu
bringen
da mussten wir sie quasi ein bisschen
anschubsen dann wäre relativ clever von
der afg und alle wären drauf
reingefallen
wir schauen noch einmal ins plenum denn
es fühlt sich doch wieder wir hören dass
tatsächlich die listen also die war die
stimmzettel gedruckt wurden und man
jetzt doch relativ konsequent versucht
auf diesen dritten wahlgang zuzusteuern
herr brenner wir haben jetzt eine
situation dass wir drei kandidaten haben
das bedeutet für das ergebnis was das
verfassungsrechtlich zumindest ein
bisschen die luft draußen ist denn diese
frage wie wird gezählt 10 uhr die ja
stimmen oder sind auch die nein-stimmen
zu berücksichtigen diese frage ist da
natürlich jetzt vom tisch denn einer
wird bei den drei kandidaten die
relative mehrheit auf sich vereinigen
also wird auch der thüringer
verfassungsgerichtshof wohl nicht über
diese frage entscheiden müssen wie diese
verfassungsbestimmung auszulegen sein
wird wir schauen uns jetzt nochmal an
liebe zuschauer wie das prozedere dieser
war hier eigentlich in der verfassung
und der geschäftsordnung des landtages
geregelt ist hier die wahl in den
verschiedenen schritten in thüringen
wählte der landtag den
ministerpräsidenten im ersten und
zweiten wahlgang ist dazu eine absolute
mehrheit erforderlich kommt keine
mehrheit zustande
gibt es einen dritten wahlgang dann ist
gewählt wer die meisten stimmen hat so
steht es in der landesverfassung
doch was heißt die meisten stimmen dazu
gibt es unterschiedliche rechts
auslegungen heißt es wer am meisten
ja-stimmen bekommt egal wie viele der
ist gewählt oder nur wer mehr ja als
nein stimmen bekommt der ist gewählt
falls jemand gegen die auslegung des
wahlergebnisses klagt muss der thüringer
verfassungsgerichtshof in weimar
erklären wie die verfassung zu verstehen
ist
jetzt haben wir gerade noch eine
konstellation hier parallel am tisch
diskutiert was passiert eigentlich wenn
ein patt zustande kommt also zwei
kandidaten rechnerisch auch möglich drei
kandidaten die gleiche anzahl aber was
passiert denn dann ja dann fehlt das
erfordernis der mehrheit dann ist kein
kandidat gewählt und dann müsste ein
neuer wahlgang stattfinden in der
hoffnung dass dann einer dieser drei
kandidaten die relative mehrheit auf
sich vereinigt ein partner bringt eben
keinen sieger hervor und deswegen wäre
dann ein weiterer wahlgang vonnöten gab
es in der tat schon bei heide simonis
wenn man sich erinnert in flüssig hohe
anlagen gab es im dritten wahlgang ein
patt zwischen
und peter harry carstensen und der cdu
so ist es und dann wurde eben ein neuer
wahlgang angesetzt in dem dann ein
anderer als vielleicht ursprünglich
erwartet zum ministerpräsidenten gewählt
wurde können so erinnern an die wahl von
christine lieberknecht 2009 die ja auch
einen dritten wahlgang braucht wenn sie
noch mal beschreiben was damals passiert
ist denn dann gab es plötzlich an die
gegenkandidaten ramelow
ja so ist es war also frau lieberknecht
in den ersten beiden wahlgängen nicht
mit der erforderlichen absoluten
mehrheit gewählt worden
und herr ramelow hat sich dann im
dritten wahlgang als kandidat zur
verfügung gestellt und damit hat man
auch damals dieses auslegungs fordern
ist oder die schwierigkeiten diese
verfassungsbestimmung auszulegen
umschifft weil er dann klar war bei zwei
kandidaten der die mehrheit der stimmen
auf sich vereinigt frau lieberknecht hat
dann gewonnen
herr ramelow hat verloren auch damals
war es nicht erforderlich dann nach
weimar zum verfassungsgerichtshof zu
ziehen und heute sieht es so aus als ob
das auch nicht erforderlich werden würde
da sagen sie es die luft raus wir
schauen jetzt mal in den plenarsaal
rhein dort fühlen sich jetzt die reihen
auch die fdp fraktion haben wir gesehen
ist jetzt komplett im saal und harrt der
dinge und der eröffnung des dritten
wahlgangs für ein hügel neben herrn
braga fehlt noch ganz vorn rechts der
habe mit dem rücken zu uns ist der
geschäftsführer der fdp-fraktion links
daneben sitzt der fraktionschef das ist
der höchste der momentan noch nicht an
seinem platz ist wir sehen hier bodo
ramelow der sich und da bin ich mir
relativ sicher im vorfeld sicherlich
auch mit dieser konstellation befasst
haben wird er wird sich darüber gedanken
gemacht haben was passiert wohl in
diesem dritten wenn tatsächlich ja diese
mehrheits frage vielleicht
verfassungsrechtlich nicht mehr steht
aber wohl plötzlich die möglichkeit ins
spiel kommt das entgegen
also eine mehrheit gegen ihn entstehen
kann zumal ja auch aus der linken immer
wieder die aufrufe kam an die anderen
fraktionen stellt doch einen kandidaten
auf um das ganze diesen diskussionen
abzukürzen
und am ende hat man doch darauf gehört
in der tat sollte auch heute gesehen
haben oben auf der besuchertribüne noch
einmal zur erklärung das war der afg
kandidat etwas versteckt mittlerweile in
der zweiten reihe
kindervater neben ihm der
bundestagsabgeordnete der asd herr
brandner der also auch hier dieses
geschehen verfolgt der ursprünglich aus
einem wahlkreis in gera stammt und in
den bundestag entsandt wurde für die afd
kindervater schaut sich das jetzt alles
an
hier sehen wir hatten kemmerich den
dritten kandidaten der seine kandidatur
abhängig gemacht hat davon ob die afd
bei ihrem kandidaten bleibt und nach dem
ist aus deren reihen hieß denn wir
bleiben auch im dritten wahlgang bei
christoph kindervater dem ehrenamtlichen
bürgermeister von so 1000 mit 350
einwohnern bislang ein unbeschriebenes
blatt hat auch thomas kemmerich von der
fdp gesagt okay dann werfe ich meinen
hut in den ring und bekannte zu hören
was da wohl gerade besprochen wird und
man würde wohl gerne wissen dass der ein
oder andere dann da jetzt gerade durch
den kopf geht denn es sicherlich auch
herr kemmerich ist sich der lage bewusst
wir rekapitulieren noch mal rot rot grün
hat 42 stimmen braucht aber für die wahl
von bodo ramelow 46 stimmen wobei er zum
dritten genau das ist bislang nicht
gelungen und jetzt kommt es eben zu
diesem dritten wahlgang wo es
tatsächlich auf die meisten stimmen
ankommt da ist egal wie viele sich
enthalten oder nein stimmen gibt es in
diesem weigern nicht und deshalb kommt
darauf an welcher kandidat hat jetzt die
meisten stimmen und da sind die karten
muss man sagen für bodo ramelow nicht
schlecht so es ist in der tat wenn man
von diesem vielleicht eher etwas
unwahrscheinlichen ergebnis absieht dass
jetzt der kandidat der fdp mit den
stimmen der ard und der cdu gewählt wird
spricht doch vieles dafür dass herr
ramelow jetzt mit was immer 44 43 42
stimmen gewählt wird das ist die
relative mehrheit und die reicht auch im
dritten wahlgang aus wir sind jetzt aus
der verfassungsrechtlichen bredouille
gewissermaßen heraus aus legen zu müssen
müssen die nein-stimmen mitgezählt
werden oder nicht das wäre nur der fall
wenn ein einziger kandidat im dritten
wahlgang zur wahl stünde aber nachdem
wir jetzt drei kandidaten haben ist die
sache verfassungsrechtlich relativ
eindeutig und wie gesagt wird auch der
thüringer verfassungsgerichtshof sich
mit dieser frage jedenfalls nicht
beschäftigen müssen
der kaufmann der präsident des
verfassungsgerichtshofes aufatmen oder
vielleicht hat das auch gerne
entschieden das weiß man nicht das
wissen wir nicht
es ist jedenfalls eine juristische
spannende frage und verfassungsrichter
sind da durchaus auch dadurch
gekennzeichnet und bekannt dass sie sich
schwierigen rechtsfragen gerne annehmen
und dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen
rechts politik betreiben zum anderen das
gefühl hat es könnte auch endlich mal
wirklich geklärt sein
denn möglicherweise steht das bei
anderen wahlen jahr wieder an diese
große frage und der großen schlagen also
ist es die frage wird sicherlich wieder
auftauchen vielleicht nicht in fünf
jahren aber vielleicht möglicherweise
auch mal auf bundesebene bei der wahl
eines bundeskanzlers
man hätte sich vielleicht ein bisschen
juristische klarheit wünscht aber diese
beantwortung der frage wird jetzt ein
bisschen in die zukunft verschoben der
produktion auf diese unklarheit wenn man
sich das große ganze jetzt einmal
anschaut ist diese unsicherheit auch das
auslegen dritter wahlgang keine mehrheit
verändert sich da was im politischen
system das gab es ja es gibt zwar
einzelne fallbeispiele aber häufig gab
es ja klare mehrheiten
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sich
wirklich etwas verändert wir haben
gerade eine besondere situation in
thüringen
auch im vergleich zu den anderen ost
ländern an diesem punkt wir haben hier
eine sehr starke linkspartei und eine
sehr starke afd
wenn wir nach sachsen brandenburg
geguckt haben da war immer nur eine
dieser gruppen so stark und nur aus
dieser variante bestand dieses cdu
problem zwischen diesen parteien
das ist so spezifisch im moment dass ich
noch nicht sehe dass wir eine ähnliche
konstellation keine mehrheiten finden
sich in den anderen landtagen
tatsächlich für die nahe zukunft
befürchten müssen und wir haben in der
vergangenheit auch gesehen da hat man ja
jetzt auch koalition geschlossen die man
vor zehn fünfzehn jahren auch nicht für
denkbar gehalten hat spd cdu und grüne
regieren zusammen inzwischen das
funktioniert hier halt alle diese
varianten nicht funktioniert aber das
liegt an dieser besonderen afd und linke
stärke in thüringen und wenn man gerade
an sachsen anhalt denkt da wird im
nächsten jahr gewählt das heißt sie
befürchten dort keine wiederholung im
moment nicht ich glaube die situation
ist nicht so vergleichbar was man
befürchten kann ist dass diese
regierungsbündnisse gegen afd noch
größer werden also von 3 auf 4 parteien
anwachsen an dieser stelle darauf dass
bei ihnen nicht leicht da was das
regieren keinesfalls leichter macht was
unzufriedenheit wieder in der
bevölkerung schürt der mond von der
immer oppositionsparteien natürlich dann
auch profitieren nicht mehr fragen kann
man das überhaupt durchhalten haben wir
momentan eine situation dass fast ein
viertel der thüringer wähler momentan
keine berücksichtigung gefunden hat in
diesem ganzen verhandlungsprozess in den
letzten monaten wie lange sowas
durchzuhalten
ach das kann man eigentlich lange
durchhalten demokratie lebt von
mehrheiten also sie brauchen 50plus
warum ich an dieser stelle das ist immer
die lösung und die polarisierte
gesellschaften werden desto wichtiger
wird auch diese knappe entscheidung an
dieser stelle deswegen würde ich schon
sagen das ist demokratisch immer aus
zweiten jede gruppe will mit anderen
gruppen mehrheiten bilden
und wenn eine gruppe 24 prozent hat auch
wenn sie 30 wenn sich 40 prozent hat
wenn die 60 anderen 60 haben ist man
raus helmut kohl hat einmal im bundestag
ich glaube eine bundestagswahl mit 46
prozent gewonnen und ist danach nicht
kanzler geworden weil eine andere
mehrheit aus spd und fdp eben in der
summe etwas mehr prozente hatte und das
ist demokratie leichte verzögerung sagen
wir mal so dann später zum zuge
herzlichen dank für einen moment jetzt
schauen wir noch mal in den plenarsaal
rein was ich da inzwischen tut wie weit
man denn ist mit dem dritten wahlgang
ja man wartet das ist der entscheidende
punkt ich glaube auch die wir warten
schon mehrfach diese sitzung ist schon
mehrfach unterbrochen worden aber jetzt
geht zwei sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete ich beginne mit der
fortsetzung der sitzung und darf sie
darauf hinweisen dass wir uns vor dem
dritten wahlgang befinden
die fraktion der fdp hat ihren
wahlvorschlag eingereicht er liegt ihnen
in drucksache 7 strich 242 jeden
abgeordneten jeder abgeordneten vor
eingereicht wurde thomas kemmerich
sehr geehrte damen und herren gemäß
artikel 70 absatz 3 satz 3 der
verfassung des freistaats thüringen und
§ 47 satz 3 der geschäftsordnung ist
gewählt wer in einem weiteren wahlgang
die meisten stimmen erhält wenn im
ersten und im zweiten wahlgang niemand
die stimmen der mehrheit der mitglieder
des landtages erhalten hat vorgeschlagen
für diesen dritten wahlgang sind erneut
herr abgeordneter bodo ramelow
herr christoph kindervater außerdem hat
die fraktion der fdp herrn abgeordneten
thomas kemmerich vorgeschlagen
sie erhalten wieder einen stimmzettel
auf dem sie entweder für eine kandidatin
beziehungsweise einem kandidaten
votieren oder sich enthalten können
ich bitte die wahlhelferinnen und
wahlhelfer herrn abgeordneten gott weiß
frau abgeordnete dr kliesch und frau
abgeordnete dr bergner erneut nach vorn
ich eröffne damit die wahlhandlung und
bitte die schriftführerinnen
beziehungsweise schriftführer die namen
der abgeordneten zu verlesen bitteschön
adams dirk und damit beginnt der reigen
von vorne alphabet wird aufgerufen
es beginnt ist gerade aufgestanden der
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen dirk
adams der dem alphabet nach zuerst der
also ein stimmrecht ausüben darf
wir haben jetzt schon ein bisschen
erfahrung von diesem tag gesammelt wir
wissen das dauert jetzt eine ganze weile
bis alle abgeordneten aufgerufen sind
und jetzt halt nehmen wir uns nochmal
zeit zu gucken was erwarten eigentlich
die thüringer von ihrer neuen regierung
von ihrem neuen ministerpräsidenten
egal wäre das heute am ende des tages
ist was fordern sie von der politik für
thüringen für die nächsten fünf jahre
sichere arbeitsplätze
sicheres einkommen für die leute und das
eben industrie vielleicht hier also
hochwertige arbeitsplätze kommen die
renten endlich mal steuerfrei
man muss ich ja mal hat angst vor jeder
rentenerhöhung weil das finanzamt
kassiert papa marc wegen der witwenrente
zu viel hat ja aber ich muss jetzt gehen
meine tochter wartet die stärkung des
öffentlichen nahverkehrs gerade so in
den städten aber auch im land dass sich
leute die auf dem land wohnen nicht
abgehängt fühlen sondern auch
partizipieren an den vielen angeboten
daher würde ich mir wünschen dass viele
projekte die angestrebt sind zum
beispiel pfefferminz bahn habe ich mal
gehört wenn das weiter geführt wird dass
wir nicht super ich denke wir haben
einen ziemlich kaputte bildungssystem
und ich würde mir wünschen dass die kids
nicht so viel druck in der schule haben
wenige noten und mehr übersicht lernen
können und das finden wir gerade fast
überhaupt nicht und glauben wir dass es
muss was da ändern
ja und jetzt wissen wir der dritte
wahlgang läuft gerade das gibt uns noch
mal gelegenheit mit
vertreter von thüringer
gesellschaftlichen gruppen zu sprechen
wir haben hier bei uns vom lehrerverband
tim reukauf und sie beobachten dass die
ganze zeit hier mit uns im studio stehen
hinter den kameras gucken genau auf
unsere monitor
was geht ihnen durch den kopf jetzt wo
es diesen dritten wahlgang geht mit drei
kandidaten genau das bleibt wahnsinnig
spannend und das wussten wir schon nach
der wahl und wir haben in unserem herbst
appell einige punkte gefordert von den
parteien und das muss einfach umgesetzt
werden eine schnellere
einstellungspolitik eine bessere
einstellung dass ich in den schulen was
bewegt christlich fragt sich jetzt mal
eiskalt sie können auch mit der
schaltung stimmen auch wenn wir keinen
stimmzettel da haben aber welchen dieser
drei ministerpräsidenten kandidaten
finden sie jetzt als sicht gewerkschaft
der polizei in thüringen am besten sie
haben sich das weiß ich im vorfeld
natürlich auch mit wahlprogramm
beschäftigt sie wissen was die einzelnen
parteien eigentlich fordern was wäre aus
ihrer sicht das sinnvollste
das ist echt eine nicht ganz um gemeinde
frage das stück ich habe auch
enthaltungen sie können auch einhalten
das mache ich nicht
in dem moment bei der konstellation die
wir momentan angebot haben werde meine
stimme in richtung bodo ramelow gehen
weil das dann auch was mit sich also
dass man auch mit sicherheit so genug im
sinne von berechenbarkeit
das hat was mit berechenbarkeit zu tun
wir haben hinter bodo ramelow momentan
schon feststehen das kabinett man kann
man kennt bestimmte leute
wir haben eine relativ stabile
keine mehrheit habe doch eine recht
große gruppe von parlamentariern die
dieser regiert diese regierungsform auf
eine minderheitsregierung ist stützen
würde
deswegen werde die entscheidung bei mir
so vor herrscht bei ihnen gleich weiter
gefragt repräsentanten der ihk hier in
thüringen
ich tippe sie würden ihre stimme haben
kameras gehen
das will ich jetzt gar nicht so
beantworten es bleibt ja festzustellen
dass egal wer jetzt gleich gewählt
werden wird wie es mit einer
minderheitsregierung zu tun haben und
das bedeutet nach wie vor und das ist
für uns als wirtschaftlich gesagt ja
auch eine chance wir müssen gemeinsam
lösungen finden im sinne unseres
standortes und finde das wohl ist das
freistaat ist werden wir sehen dass der
wahlgang auch hier fortgesetzt wird noch
mal die frage auch an sie weiß natürlich
größere baustellen soll jetzt einen
förderfonds aufgesetzt werden das steht
zumindest zum koalitionsvertrag
wenn rot-rot-grün zustande kommt
da hat der wird doch nur der arme zu
greifen ist das sinnvoll das ist auf
jeden fall das alles sinnvoll was die
wirtschaft hier am standort unterstützt
gleichwohl der koalitionsvertrag aus
unserer sicht sehr oberflächlich sehr
auslegungs wirklich uns auch entschieden
von daher muss man sich den dann nochmal
im einzelnen auch mit den beteiligten
personen anschauen
aber die themen die unsere unseren immer
nach unten bewegen ist das eine
fachkräftemangel das ist das andere dass
wir auf eine konjunktur jetzt suchen die
eben nicht mehr so üppige einnahmen auch
dem land beschert
von daher müssen wir uns hier wie gesagt
für ein klima der
wirtschaftsfreundlichkeit für ein klima
auch der weltoffenheit ganz wichtig auch
für potenzielle investoren kümmern
und wir müssen unseren unternehmern hier
vor ort und da kann die landesregierung
durchaus auch ihren beitrag leisten
effiziente bezahlbare und möglichst
digitalisierte verwaltungsstrukturen zur
verfügung stellen heraf sie denken
weniger an die wirtschaft vielmehr an
die kinder an thüringer schulen welchen
der drei kandidaten trauen sie zu dass
er die lehrer problematik den unterrock
tor laura oder noch massiv ist in
thüringen anschließen lässt
genau wir denken vor allem an die kinder
an die zukunft von thüringen und als
sprecher des jungen thüringer
lehrerverbandes werde ich aber diese
frage nicht beantworten also ich
persönlich weiß wo ich mein kreuz setzen
würde und kann mich da meinen beiden
vorrednern anschließend auf der einen
seite haben
jährlich die sicherheit und da kommen
wir wieder zu der ersten frage die sie
ganz am anfang der sendung gestellt
haben
alle parteien wollen was für die schulen
machen wollen mehr lehrer einstellen die
unterrichts abdeckung sichern und das
muss endlich in die tat umgesetzt werden
sie haben das gefühl das ist offenbar
mit allen möglich wir nutzen jetzt die
gelegenheit nochmal und schauen ins
plenum wo jetzt nach wie vor der dritte
wahlgang läuft wir hören man bei welchem
buchstaben wir inzwischen angekommen
sind
lookeen guten also wir sind gerade bei
hannover lag aufgerufen das ist der
geschäftsführer der cdu fraktion
ebenfalls neu im amt
maier georg georg maier von der spd
amtierender innenminister soll auch
innenminister bleiben wenn es wieder auf
eine minderheitsregierung daneben von
rot-rot-grün zuläuft magst du tier aber
das heißt das ganze dauert noch starben
er wird sich noch ein bisschen hinziehen
hilde bei den abgeordneten wald oder
folk zum beispiel angelastet das dauert
noch und das gibt uns die zeit mal zu
gucken welche aufgaben eigentlich auf
dieser neue thüringer regierung warten
goethe und schiller bauhaus in weimar
die wartburg thüringen hat viel schönes
hier im miniaturenpark genereller zu
bestaunen im kleinformat dabei sind die
aufgaben die auf die nächste
landesregierung zu rollen eher xl
da wäre das thema bildung und schule
laut einer umfrage von infratest dimap
für die bürger das mit abstand größte
problem im land
es fehlen lehrer unterricht fällt
dadurch aus zwar hat die landesregierung
angekündigt mehr lehrer ausbilden und
zusätzliche einstellungstermin schaffen
zu wollen
das reiche aber nicht sagen unter
anderem gewerkschaftler er zu viele
arbeitskräfte auf zu wenig stellen
könnte es bald in der automobilindustrie
geben einem der wichtigsten
industriezweige in thüringen bis zu 3000
jobs könnten in den kommenden jahren
wegfallen
unter anderem wegen der umstellung auf e
mobilität und weltweiter handels
probleme wirtschaftlich außerdem ein
problem das lohnniveau nur in
mecklenburg vorpommern gibt es noch mehr
niedriglöhner jeder dritte thüringer
arbeitet für weniger als zehn euro
brutto die stunde auch die energiewende
beschäftigt thüringen bis 2040 will sich
der freistaat komplett aus erneuerbaren
energien versorgen
doch der ausbau von windenergie
stagniert es gibt eine starke lobby
gegen die windkraft doch nicht nur das
auch die debatte über stromautobahnen
die durch thüringen führen
wollen wird emotional geführt ein
politikum sind inzwischen auch die
thüringer wälder trockenheit und
borkenkäfer haben der natur enorm
zugesetzt
nur noch 15 prozent der bäume im
freistaat gelten als gesund rot rot grün
hat zwar schon ein nothilfeprogramm
aufgelegt aber ob das ausreicht
thüringen im herbst 2009 10
auch wenn die staatskanzlei hier im
miniaturenpark so klein erscheint auf
die nächsten chef im haus warten große
aufgaben und dieser chef das könnte
eventuell bodo ramelow sein der in
diesem augenblick seine stimme abgibt
und wieder leben wir uns glaube ich
nicht so weit aus dem fenster wenn wir
sagen er wird wohl für sich selbst
stimmen
ich glaube davon gehen wir gehen wir aus
wir sind mittel ramelow beim buchstaben
r angekommen
das heißt das ganze geht aufs ende zu
die spannung steigt
er hat es offenbar gern getan und
lächeln man möchte gern wissen was jetzt
in seinem kopf vorgeht
aus seinem umfeld heißt es er ist
durchaus angespannt in diesem wald hat
gegangen hat sich gestern noch einmal
aus allen terminen rausnehmen lassen am
nachmittag nachdem und um am ende dann
noch mal ein spaziergang zu machen mit
seinem hund und seiner ehefrau
so hat er diesem wahlgang tag sozusagen
in angriff genommen
und tatsächlich ist das ja ein
schwieriger tag für ihn am ende weiß er
nicht wird erst noch mal ordentlich
professor bord hat die sache ist jetzt
vor allem im dritten wahlgang sehr offen
ich glaube die hoffnung bestand in der
tat im zweiten wahlgang spätestens doch
gewählt zu sein
diese hoffnung hat sich nicht erfüllt
und jetzt haben wir in der tat eine
konstellation mit einem kandidaten aus
cdu und fdp
der womöglich rein rechnerisch eine
mehrheit kriegen könnte die höher ist
als die wieder ein hammer kommt jetzt
könnte es wie auch immer ausgeführten
ramelow oder vielleicht auch für herrn
kämmerer kemmerich könnte durchaus sehr
viele stimmen bekommen auch noch einige
von der afd wenn wir uns mal dieses
szenario anschauen ist jetzt eine tür
geöffnet mit dieser wahl schon in
richtung afd meinen sie dass es dort
vielleicht im nachgang noch eher zu
einer zusammenarbeit so einen absprachen
kommen könnte oder hat das eigentlich
diese wahl mit dem was man immer gesagt
hat wir wollen nicht mit der stadt
zusammenarbeiten nichts zu tun
für die cdu ändert sich erst mal relativ
wenig weil es kein cdu kandidat ist der
durch auf die stimmen gewählt werden
würde
deswegen glaube ich nicht dass wir hier
eine bewegung haben werden in der
zukunft würde sie sich stellen wenn wir
tatsächlich dann eine cdu/fdp-regierung
hätten unter fdp-führung die von der afg
toleriert werden würde auch ohne
abkommen aber zumindest faktisch das
wäre schon eine besondere konstellation
an dieser stelle aber ich glaube nicht
dass die frage auf ob die frage wird er
auf ploppen konntet ihr das nicht
erwarten dass das im dritten wahlgang
passiert und auf die antwort auf diese
frage da bin ich dann sehr gespannt wir
müssen sagen im voraus gab es ja
mehrfach avancen der ard in richtung fdp
und cdu dass man doch gemeinsam so hans
böke im landtag formuliert so viel
erreichen können
und da wurde immer abgefunden das wäre
jetzt sozusagen durch die hintertür von
derart dann doch geschafft die art wie
wir erfolgreich gewesen sie hätte die
anderen beiden parteien
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen vor sich hin
getrieben aber mit einem geschickt
reagieren geschubst in die richtige ecke
und dann eine konstellation
herbeigeführt die das ergebnis hat was
ihr vorgeschwebt hat nämlich ein
kandidat der nicht aus der linken seite
kommt sondern von der afg der cdu und
der fdp gestützt wird professor brenner
wir haben gesehen in dem beitrag vor hin
dass die liste der aufgaben wirklich
eine sehr lange ist jetzt ist die große
frage
die liste der aufgaben ist lang kam der
minderheitsregierung egal wer sie dann
führen da überhaupt viel leisten viel
anstoßen und hat so ein
ministerpräsident der teilnahme
minderheitsregierung ist überhaupt genug
power und die frage ist vielleicht
zweigeteilt zu beantworten was politisch
verwirklichbar ist das ist eine frage
die von fall zu fall zu entscheiden ist
die parteien oder die fraktionen müssen
sich zusammenfinden
die andere frage ist dann was
tatsächlich zu erwarten ist ist bleibt
schwierig und wir werden sehen wie sich
die parteien politisch verständigen
werden
danke so weit der bremer
verfassungsrechtler der universität jena
wir schauen noch einmal ins plenum in
den landtag wie weit man mit dem
wahlgang ist
wir sehen an dieser stelle herrn valcke
der generalsekretär der cdu
buchstabe w wer also jetzt hier seinen
stimmzettel in empfang nimmt und stimme
abgeben wird dh das ende des alphabets
ist na dann wird wieder einzeln
ausgezählt im plenarsaal selbst in das
ganze muss öffentlich stattfinden von
der wahlkommission und einigen
abgeordneten
es wird wieder eine ganze weile dauern
weil das ganze immer noch per hand
passiert man mag es kaum glauben da wird
wirklich jeder stimmzettel durchgezählt
dann noch banken alle abgeordneten ihre
stimme abgeben
dann stelle ich fest dass alle
abgeordneten ihre stimme abgeben konnten
ich schließe die wahlhandlung und bitte
um die auszählung der stimmen bitte
schön und es geht los
wichtig dieser satz von der
landtagspräsidentin
alle ihre stimme abgeben denn das hätte
den ganzen wahlgang ungültig machen wenn
das nicht die möglichkeit gewesen wäre
dabei immer so ein kleiner fallstrick
sind vor allem auch die zum wahlhelfer
bestimmten abgeordneten ob sie denn auch
tatsächlich dann aus ihrer funktion des
wahlhelfers heraus ihre stimme abgeben
konnten ebenfalls die
landtagspräsidentin birgit keller ist
gewählter abgeordneter und muss
ebenfalls ihre stimme abgeben nur zum
verständnis warum immer wieder dann nach
diesen wahl gegen diese frage kommt
konnten alle ihre stimme abgeben und
bisher hat das ja auch alles geklappt es
waren immer 90 abgegebenen stimmen also
genauso viele abgeordnete wie im landtag
setzen
herr brenner die verfassungsfrage ist
durch diese drei kandidaten erst einmal
sein dass sich vertagt sie raus also
jetzt nicht beantwortet werden dh die
verkündung des ergebnisses obliegt jetzt
dem präsidium
ja es wird die landtagspräsidentin dann
anschließend bekannt geben wer die
meisten stimmen auf sich vereinigt hat
und derjenige der auf denen das zutrifft
der wird dann von ihrem voraussichtlich
zum ministerpräsidenten ernannt werden
und auf ihre frage noch mal
zurückzukommen der ministerpräsident der
nur mit relativer mehrheit gewählt ist
der ist natürlich voll umfänglich in das
amt des ministerpräsidenten gekommen er
hat alle befugnisse die auch ein
ministerpräsident der mit absoluter
mehrheit gewählt worden wäre
es ist also dieser dieser
ministerpräsident der noch mit relativer
mehrheit gewählt wurde nichts
minderwertiges er ist mit der verfassung
oder von der verfassung mit allen
befugnissen ausgestattet die auch ein
mit absoluter mehrheit gewählte
ministerpräsident hätte das hat ja das
hat aber die konstellation natürlich
auch zur folge dass wenn jetzt solche
bodo ramelow gewählt werden würde ist
die kleine besonderheit gibt er muss ja
letztendlich auch keine mehrheit im
landtag rücksicht nehmen da hat er
schlicht und ergreifend keine kann er
dadurch politisch etwas freier agieren
das würde ich nicht so sehen weil er
braucht ja mehrheiten im landtag um
jedes vorhaben jedes gesetz
durchzubringen ohne geht es nicht an
dieser stelle
das heißt in jedem einzelfall muss man
neu verhandeln wir haben schon die
verhandlungen im vorfeld mit den
koalitionspartnern dann die verhandlung
mit der oppositionspartei ein sehr
langwieriger prozess
ich glaube nicht dass das spaß macht
aber kann es am ende doch passieren dass
er mehr die opposition und deren
abgeordnete und wirbt als die eigenen
leute zu helfen
ja wahrscheinlich ja umgekehrt ist es so
es werden nur die gesetzesvorhaben
vorangebracht werden die sowieso eine
mehrheit in der koalition erst einmal
haben das heißt hier müssen erstmal die
interessen berücksichtigt werden das was
man im koalitionsvertrag verabredet hat
und dann geht man erst auch die anderen
partner in der opposition dann zu und
wenn sich da im vorfeld schon eine
szenario abzeichnet zu viele
zugeständnisse vielleicht bei cdu und
fdp
dann wird man es vielleicht gar nicht
angehen an dieser stelle um das zu
vermeiden
die zuschauer falls ihr jetzt erst
eingeschaltet haben diese sind ihren
live mit einem mdr extra aus erfurt von
der ministerpräsidenten wahl in
thüringen
der dritte wahlgang es sieht so aus wir
schauen mal rein ist abgeschlossen jetzt
wird ausgezählt
bislang gibt es keinen kandidaten der
sich durchgesetzt hat bodo ramelow hatte
in den ersten beiden wahlgängen keine
mehrheit bekommen deshalb jetzt ein
dritter wahlgang mit 2 gegen kanada im
ersten wahlgang hätte bodo ramelow 46
stimmen gebraucht oder auch herr
kindervater von der af de erreicht hat
bodo ramelow im ersten wahlgang 43
stimmen also eine stimme mehr als
rot-rot-grün sitze hat man sich eine
wahlhelferin die backen auf posten das
ergebnis scheint vor zu denen es ist
spekulation immer das heißen mag aber
gut dann haben wir auch den zweiten kann
auch das wollen wir nicht vorenthalten
hier ebenfalls keine mehrheit bodo
ramelow 44 also nochmal ein mehr den er
bekommen hat im zweiten wagen aber es
waren eben nicht die erforderlichen 46
damit war ja auch hier nicht gewählt und
da das ganze händisch passiert wundern
sie sich vielleicht warum das so lange
dauert bisher 90 zettel ausgezählt
werden
das ist eben zum einen der grund das
ganze passiert von hand und der andere
grund ist das dann natürlich noch mal
gegen gezählt werden muss damit das auch
wirklich alles seine ordnung hat denn
ansonsten professor brenner gibt es im
nachhinein problem weil protokollarisch
was nicht hingehauen
so ist es und dass er natürlich nicht
vorteilhaft auch nicht für den thüringer
landtag deswegen muss ja alles ganz
geordnet vonstatten gehen so wie es auch
im bundestag üblich ist um hinterher
auch mögliche anfechtungen
aus dem weg zu räumen das heißt es wird
hier ganz geschäftsordnungs mäßig
vorgegangen um dann am schluss ein vor
anfechtungen freies ergebnis zu erzielen
und da hören wir mal ob ist dieses
ergebnis denn jetzt vielleicht langsam
geht wir schauen noch mal rein
die auszählung läuft noch man will
offenbar auf nummer sicher gehen
nachvollziehbare gründe dass man sieht
jemanden die zahlen aufschreiben die
unterschiedlichen zählergebnisse die
zumindest jetzt von den augen dort das
sind mehr als vier augen überwacht
werden wie gesagt auch hier mit am tisch
die abgeordneten die das ganze mit
beobachten plus die mitarbeiter der
landtagsverwaltung die als
zählkommission hier agieren sie stammen
aus dem kreis der schriftführer und
werten diese wahlzettel dann in einer
gesonderten mappe beim präsidium abgeben
auf dass das ganze dann auch im
nachhinein überprüfbar ist und werden
auf einem gesonderten zettel der
landtagspräsidentin das ergebnis
verkünden hier sehen wir die bündel der
stimmzettel
sie werden jetzt in einen umschlag getan
die gesagt um sie im nachhinein
überprüfen zu können und in wenigen
augenblicken wird birgit keller von der
linken das ergebnis bekommen
dre sind spannende augenblick auch für
bodo ramelow vor allem für gute luft
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich gebe
die anzahl der abgegebenen stimmen
bekannt abgegebene stimmzettel 90
gültige stimmzettel 90 enthaltungen eine
auf den wahlvorschlag der fraktion die
linke der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
drucksache 7 strich 204 für abgeordnete
bodo ramelow stimmten 44 stimmen
wahlvorschlag der fraktion der afg in
drucksache 7 strich 240er christoph
kindervater 0 stimmen wahlvorschlag der
fraktion der fdp drucksache 7 strich 242
abgeordneter thomas kemmerich 45 ja
stimmen haben wir das ergebnis das man
merkt es auch ist griechin lage herrn
abgeordneten kemmerich nehmen sie die
wahl zum ministerpräsidenten an
dann darf ich ihnen gratulieren den
ministerpräsidenten es ist der
parteichef der fdp thomas kemmerich
das hat hier in so viele überrascht mich
schließlich den tagesordnungspunkt 1
rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 2 die
vereidigung des ministerpräsidenten des
freistaates thema nämlich wird jetzt
irgendwie so verdienten zu seiner
vereidigung plattform die anwesenden
bitte ich sich von ihren plätzen man
mehr zu erheben dass er da offenbar doch
überrascht es mit diesem ergebnis hat
wohl auch thomas kemmerich am ende doch
nicht gerechnet
das ist eine faustdicke überraschung das
muss man so deutlich sagen wir haben
über diesen fall spekuliert jetzt ist er
tatsächlich eingetreten
vereidigung des ministerpräsidenten des
freistaats thüringen sehr geehrter herr
ministerpräsident thomas kemmerich
verlesen nun die in artikel 71 der
verfassung des freistaats thüringen
vorgeschriebene eidesformel und bitte
sie diese eidesformel nach zu sprechen
sie können den eid anschließend mit den
worten so wahr mir gott helfe
bekräftigen die eidesformel lautete ich
schwöre ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft
dem wohle des volkes widmen dass ich
meine kraft dem wohle des volkes widmen
verfassung und gesetze waren verfassung
und gesetze waren meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde und
gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde
so wahr mir gott helfe
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
schließe diesen tagesordnungspunkt 2 ab
mike mohring cdu fraktionschef
gratuliert thomas kemmerich
der mann muss und noch einmal sagen aus
der fdp ist fdp-politiker eine partei
die bei der landtagswahl mit ach und
krach in den landtag gekommen ist ist da
im laufe des abends damals mehrfach so
aus als hätten die es eigentlich nicht
angeschafft
wir haben uns doch gerade gesehen dass
der fraktionsvorsitzende afd
herr hüppe gratuliert hat und auch wenn
die wahl geheim ist an dieser stelle
kann man denke ich soweit spekulieren
die afg hat ihn ins amt gehoben denn es
gab tatsächlich 0 stimmen für den
kandidaten der afg selbst das heißt die
ard hat geschlossen gestimmt und zwar
nicht für ihren eigenen kandidaten in
der tat noch mal zur verdeutlichung
während jetzt hier die abgeordneten dem
neu gewählten ministerpräsidenten das
ist gelebte tradition in allen
bundesländern gratuliert die zahl zur
verdeutlichung der afg kandidat
kindervater hat im letzten wahlgang
keine stimme bekommen
es gab eine enthaltung bodo ramelow von
der linkspartei bekommt 44 wie schon im
zweiten wahlgang das heißt es ist keiner
weiter in das lager von rot-rot-grün
rüber gewechselt und so was kann man
nicht gewinnt mit einer stimme mehrheit
mit 45 stimmen diese wahl
und jetzt wird im nachhinein natürlich
die große frage sein wie die fdp
erklären wird sich ist hier mit stimmen
der afg ins amt gehoben worden
professor brodos was wird das jetzt für
eine runde stehen das wird eine ganz
große rolle spielen das ist sozusagen
das erste mal in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik dass ein
ministerpräsident mit stimmen der afg
ins amt gewählt wurde
das hatten wir noch nicht dass es ein
historisches ereignis ohne frage und es
wird interessant zu sein die die
verantwortlichen fdp ihr vorgehen jetzt
in weiteren begründen werden weshalb
trainer als verfassungsrechtler diese
eine stimme 45 zu 44 unproblematisch
verfassungsrechtlich in jeder hinsicht
unproblematisch 45 stimmen sind eine
stimme mehr als 44 und deswegen haben
wir hier eine ganz ordnungsgemäße wahl
und wir müssen auch nicht auslegen wie
das bei allen kandidaten der fall
gewesen wäre
was nun das mehrheits erfordernis ist
wir haben hier einen
eindeutig nach den vorgaben der
verfassung gewählten neuen
ministerpräsidenten
da spielt es auch keine rolle dass die
afg nicht mit offenem visier gespielt
hat das spielt keine rolle wir haben ja
bei der ministerpräsidenten-wahl mit
guten gründen wie ich meine eine geheime
wahl
es muss keiner sich offenbaren wen er
wählt und offensichtlich ist von diesen
rechten abgeordneten hier auch in der
weise gebrauch gemacht worden dass jetzt
ein kandidat gewählt wurde mit dem
vielleicht am anfang des wagens noch
niemand wirklich gerechnet
wir haben gesehen in dem moment als die
stimmen verkündet worden dass christoph
kindervater auf der tribüne lächeln im
gesicht hatte obwohl er ja null stimmen
bekommen hat ja ich kann mir denken
weshalb er gelächelt hat das vorgehen
der afg war natürlich abgesprochen
deswegen natürlich auch diese
beratungspause
die abgeordneten der fdp haben ja
einmütig für den fdp kandidaten bestimmt
ich denke dass herr kindervater
gelächelt hat weil er letztendlich nicht
überrascht waren hervor das jetzt haben
wir einen ministerpräsidenten der erst
einmal keine regierungsmannschaft hat es
gibt letztendlich kein
regierungsprogramm spielt das eine rolle
oder kann das jetzt einfach nachgeholt
werden auch rein faktisch kann das jetzt
erstmal nachgeholt werden interessant
ist wer diese koalition stellen wird die
cdu sicherlich ist der natürliche
partner
an dieser stelle auf die afg wird man
ein großer wahrscheinlichkeit fragt die
sitzung für zwei stunden unterbrechen
dass sie ihr kabinett berufen können
sie ist das so vorgesehen dann
unterbreche ich jetzt die sitzung für
zwei stunden und um 15 uhr 30 treffen
wir uns wieder hier zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt danke ja in diesen
zwei stunden wird jetzt viel passieren
müssen denn es ist nicht davon
auszugehen dass da jetzt leute bereits
im warten als minister berufen zu werden
denn mit diesem schritt hat
wahrscheinlich wirklich auch er kann ich
nicht gerechnet habe wie wird das jetzt
weitergehen kann es am ende sein dass
der der bislang als großer verlierer
galt nämlich mike mohring jetzt im
kabinett unter thomas kemmerich
ministerposten bekommen
das würde ich nicht ausschließen also
ich denke in der tat in zwei stunden
wären jetzt genutzt werden zu besprechen
wie könnte eine erste
regierungsmannschaft aussehen die man
heute verteidigen kann
ich denke auch dass man selbst wenn man
es für sehr unwahrscheinlich hielt nicht
ganz unvorbereitet was das angeht da
gibt es mit sicherheit ein zettel mit
ein paar namen drauf
die man heute benennen kann und die auch
schon sicherlich ihre zustimmung für den
unwahrscheinlichen fall signalisiert
haben wenn das nicht der fall ist dann
werden wir völlige politische naivität
aber das erwarte ich nicht deswegen
denke ich schon
man wird jetzt noch mal zwei stunden
beraten auch wie man das in der
öffentlichkeit artikuliert diese zeit
wird man auch brauchen
die kleine mannschaft denke ich wird
stehen und sie wird aus cdu und fdp
ministern besteht was man an der stelle
der festhalten muss mit diesem neuen
ministerpräsidenten mit der erfordert
mit der jetzt gefundenen bei einer
vereinigung sind alle minister des
kabinetts ramelow aus dem abgeschnitten
so ist es die bisherige regierung
ramelow war ja seit dem zeitpunkt der
wahl nur noch geschäftsführend im amt
sie hat das amt weiter fortgeführt ohne
aber eine neue idee demokratische
legitimation durch den landtag
vermittelt bekommen zu haben
diese neue demokratische legitimation
wurde heute durch den dritten wahlgang
vermittelt und jetzt ist die regierung
nicht mehr geschäftsführer sondern
tatsächlich von den abgeordneten neu
gewählt ins amt gekommen
es ist ein schwerer tag sicherlich auch
für bodo ramelow hat das an den bildern
gerade gesehen
es gab eine aufmunternde worte glaube
ich und man hat unterstützung
das immer wieder gescheut das ganze
einen krimi zu nennen aber am ende war
es doch einer und mit dem ausgang den
alle eigentlich nicht erwartet haben
er war die ganze zeit letztendlich der
kandidat auf dem es zulief bodo ramelow
man war sich unsicher ob das im ersten
wahlgang vielleicht schon klappen viele
haben gewettet
es könnte der zweite sein weil es dann
doch einige abweichler gibt die
versuchen wollen diesen dritten wahlgang
dieses problem auch das
verfassungsrechtliche zu umgehen auch
diese politisch schwierige konstellation
wenn dann plötzlich die afg mit stimmen
sollte also war doch fielen danach
gelegen den zweiten wahlgang als den zu
nehmen wo man sagt das könnte ist dann
werden dann wurde es darin dass jetzt
das ergebnis erklärt natürlich wirklich
wo viele gerätselt haben professor pro
los was media fd mit diesem kandidaten
christoph kindervater ein bürgermeister
ehrenamtlich noch dazu der eigentlich
fast nicht hätte da sein können heute
war auf dienstreise war dann doch noch
hiermit saß auf der tribüne
das zeigt natürlich gibt die frage was
wollen die mit diesen kandidaten
inzwischen weiß man was sie mit dem
kandidaten
ich glaube sie wollten zwei sachen der
erste schritt war eine alternative
anzubieten so bodo ramelow cdu fdp
hatten bis sonntag signalisiert dies
nicht zu tun
das war der erste schritt und der zweite
schritt und der war glaube ich auch von
der art die nicht zu erwarten dass dann
die fdp auf einmal sagt jan im dritten
wahlgang würden wir gegebenenfalls einen
dritten kandidaten ins rennen schicken
und das war glaube ich strategisch
spielte dass der fc in die karten
endlich haben cdu und fdp aus ihrer
perspektive jemand aus ihren reihen
gefunden den sie nominieren
die afg hat vorher immer signalisiert
dass sie bereit wäre einen solchen
kandidaten zu wählen
davon kauft keiner ernsthaft überrascht
seien an dieser stelle und dann war das
spiel noch mal ganz neu auf und ist für
die afg hinten raus aufgegangen und wir
schreiben noch mal zu unserem kollegen
markus reha in berlin sehen wir ihn da
markus gibt es erste reaktionen auf
diesen paukenschlag hieraus auch schon
gehört adenauer-haus kommentar in etwa
wir sind genauso überrascht wie sie es
wahrscheinlich sind wir müssen uns jetzt
erstmal sortieren das ist die reaktion
der bundes cdu
von der bundes fdp haben wir noch keine
reaktion vorliegen auch dabei hat man
uns auf eine reaktion zu warten
eine reaktion der linken auch von der
linkspartei haben wir noch keine
reaktion das ist ja tatsächlich ein doch
überraschendes ergebnis auch wenn es
dabei thomas kemmerich dem jetzt
gewählten ministerpräsidenten gestern
schon eine leise vorahnung gab
wie muss man das einschätzen haben sich
die parteizentralen mit diesem bei
dieser konstellation in diesem möglichen
fall dass thomas kann man sich jetzt
gewählt wird im vorhinein wirklich
ernsthaft beschäftigt was ist ihr
eindruck
auf den ersten blick macht das jetzt den
eindruck als habe man solch eine
möglichkeit ausgeschlossen habe man nur
in kühnsten träumen wenn ich das so
salopp formulieren darf damit gerechnet
dass die afg wirklich ein solches
manöver fährt da scheint man also hier
in berlin wirklich überrumpelt worden zu
sein von der a f d markus vielleicht
noch eine kurze frage zu den
konstellationen die sich jetzt auch tun
ist das eine art tabubruch da passiert
wird lässt sich das jetzt schon sagen
oder ist das schlicht und ergreifend
noch zu früheren zu frisch das ist
sicherlich noch früher wir haben
natürlich thomas kemmerich gestern auch
danach gefragt
er war da nicht ganz klar was ihm
vorschwebt ist eine bürgerliche
regierung eine regierung die nahe bei
den bürgern ist in ihrer politik die im
alltag an den alltagssorgen der
bürgerinnen und bürger einsetzt und die
sich ganz klar trennt und distanziert
von der afg mit der ard will thomas
kemmerich unter keinen umständen
zusammenarbeiten
für ihn war ein ganz wichtiges thema was
er für thüringen angehen will die
digitalisierung und er will um die
voranzutreiben experten in seine
regierung holen
marcus trier unser kollege aus berlin zu
der frage ob die parteizentralen dass
das hier in zügen passiert ist als
tabubruch werten oder nicht danke ja und
bei uns sind jetzt akteure dieses
vormittags begrüße neben mir den
fraktionsvorsitzenden der spd guten tag
herr heil bei uns auch der
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen hat am
sonntag und da ich beginnt einmal bei
ihnen die momentane gefühlslage
na ja man ist ein bisschen paralysiert
weil etwas eingetreten ist was wir uns
in den kühnsten träumen in dem falle
albträumen nicht habe vorstellen können
und natürlich ein bisschen aufgewühlt
aber im grunde haben wir alle facetten
dieses dritten wahlgangs schon mal
durchgespielt das war die
unwahrscheinlichste variante jetzt ist
er eingetreten und jetzt muss man damit
umgehen die unwahrscheinlichste variante
sagt herr h wie erklären sie sich dass
das passiert ist also für mich ist das
erstmal ein politischer kulturbruch die
bürgerlichen parteien cdu und fdp haben
mit einer von einem faschisten gefühl
fraktionen zusammen eine koalition
geschmiedet man hat ein abgestimmtes
verhalten heute sehen können und
insofern war ist willentlich so diesen
rechten mit andy in die
regierungsverantwortung zu helfen und
das ist glaube ich ein tabubruch der
deutschlandweit beachtet werden muss und
ich denke dass ich dazu die
bundesparteien verhalten werden
die nachfrage nun war das ganze
natürlich ein demokratischer vorgang und
das ist auch verfassungsrechtlich alles
sauber abgelaufen herr kemmerich ist
gewählt und nun schlicht und ergreifend
ministerpräsident des freistaates
thüringen muss man mit einer mehrheit
jenseits von rot-rot-grün einfach leben
wenn es sie gibt also auf jeden fall
natürlich ich habe herrn kemmerich
gratuliert ist eine demokratische wahl
dennoch ist meine politische beurteilung
dieser demokratischen wahl sehr klar das
ist ein politischer kulturbruch werden
sie herr heil jetzt trotzdem in dem was
ansteht in den nächsten fünf jahren
blockieren oder werden sie auch mit
dieser regierung thomas kemmerich
stimmen wenn es auf ihre mehrheit an
gibt denn auch diese
minderheitsregierung ist ja auch die
stimmen der opposition angewiesen nur
dass sie da wird sind also auch meine
abgeordneten demand fraktionen werden
jemand dort sehr pflichtbewusst und sehr
gut wahrnehmen es ist allerdings so dass
gestern abend herr kemmerich schon so
ein angebot gemacht hat sollte er denn
ministerpräsident werden in klammern
naja dann hat die afg mich eben mit
gewählt dann würde ich spd ministern
auch in meinem kabinett den vorrang
geben und ich kann ihn jetzt schon mal
sorgen sozialdemokratischen minister
arbeiten nicht mit einem
ministerpräsidenten zusammen der von dfb
gewählt wurde und punkt das heißt eine
zusammenarbeit an dieser stelle mit
einer fdp geführten regierung lehnen sie
ab wir arbeiten im parlament mit aber
wir arbeiten nicht zusammen mit der fdp
nicht unter diesen umständen und sie
muss auch allein verantworten was da
heute geschehen ist ich habe ein großes
faible eigentlich für liberale politik
die in diesem land auch viel gestaltet
hat aber das was die liberalen heute
hier in thüringen vollzogen haben ist
wirklich sehr bedenklich und wie ich
finde auch für diese parteien absoluter
tiefpunkt ja jetzt haben wir diese
konstellation dass momentan überhaupt
keine regierungsmannschaft steht das
alles kommt sehr überraschend
wie geht das jetzt eigentlich weiter
werden sich viele menschen fragen wie
sollte es weitergehen aus ihrer sicht na
ja das ist eine gute frage aber die
frage muss ja kemmerich beantworten er
hat wissentlich eingepreist dass das
geschehen kann er hätte im dritten
wahlgang nicht so gut in den ring werfen
müssen ihn war klar mathematik aus der
klasse dass wenn beispielsweise ramelow
gegen kindervater allein kandidiert ist
dann mit sicherheit mehr ja-stimmen für
ramelow gegeben hätte das hat er also
bewusst in kauf genommen und jetzt ist
es an ihm der regierung zu bilden und
ich bin gespannt wie er das dann
zustande bringen will mit unserer hilfe
auf keinen fall
die werden sich die neuen gegenüber
dieser regierung verhalten wir sind in
der opposition wir werden eine
knallharte opposition sein wir hatten
eine mannschaft und ein programm
anzubieten
thomas kemmerich hat nichts davon und
das ist jetzt seine aufgabe diese fragen
zu beantworten
wiederum haben sie sich wenn sie in der
minderheitsregierung gewesen während
gewünscht dass man sie unterstützt sie
verweigern das jetzt ich habe nicht
gesagt dass ich das verweigern dass wir
in der opposition sind und thomas
kemmerich muss die frage beantworten wie
er regieren will
unser angebot war mit einem programm und
einer mannschaft ein angebot in richtung
opposition zu machen
thüringen zu gestalten dieses angebot
ist nicht gewollt worden von cdu und fdp
sie haben den faschisten in die
regierung den weg geebnet sagt dirk
adams von den grünen und das war unser
in der extra hier aus erfurt von der
wahl des thüringer ministerpräsidenten
die anders ausgegangen ist als viele
gedacht haben in der neuen
ministerpräsidenten thüringen heißt
thomas kemmerich kommt von